I wasted play game with me ray I don't
want to play a game
oh please no I said playing game with me
right man wait
family I want you to imagine a character
your boss Mickey
piss you're too smart to be blackmailing
us Fletcher hey sweet Mary Jane is my
vice so your boys on the other hand is
it always has been a destroyer of world
you're out of touch and I would like you
to consider an offer I am NOT for sale
the plot begins to thicken now I can't
be specific about the heroes and zero
but our protagonist is a hungry animal
you there is a lot of money hanging in
the balance our antagonist explodes on a
seed black a millennial firewall and has
indirectly started a war I think you
need to see this boss
[Music]
they find it make inquiries his name is
[ __ ] loose belt with a PA so I was like
[ __ ] please sorry for her kind of hock
if you smell smoke it's because there's
a fire do you get a stamp that out
quickly these people are gonna clean
house and you are part of that house in
the jungle only way a lion survives by
acting like by be brilliant
oh it's really warming up now isn't it
the lives ungry these
[Music]
my associates are not so you killed
someone no it was the gravity that
killed him do you need those phones
[Music]
[Music]